platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address HTTP during this meeting fruit
use me let's begin again HTTP colon two
slashes www soon us / j / 9 6 1 8 9 9 9
6 5 4 o or dialing 1 of the following
numbers 1 9 - 9 205 609 9 or 1 301 7 1 5
8 5 9 to be providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting we previously gave notice to
the public of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar see
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anybody has a problem please call to
seven one three 600 or email h see s at
ledge dot state dot and H dot US these
adjoining the meeting if the public is
unable to
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
reschedule I want to introduce the staff
that are on the meeting assisting us
Jennifer for House Committee researcher
is the meeting host additional House
committee services staff are providing
support
Brad Greenland is here for technical
support and Pam's Marlene and Christina
Dyer are here to assist with
facilitating the meeting this is a work
session on HB 16 FN a copy of the bill
has been posted on the main page of the
general court website under the heading
[Music]
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by role ok let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
state whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right-to-know law
the chair recognizes the Clerk of the
committee representative welfare thank
you madam chair everybody here I'm
trying to do something representative
birch represented Horrigan I'm here in
Durham and I'm presenting wood
I heard you say you're here also a long
representative library Thank You
representative all char good morning I'm
here and I am alone in my office here's
representative DiLorenzo representative
barrows we'll have to see if that has to
be reported later on
representative chase good morning I am
here this wind is getting ridiculous
that's way better representative Kenny
he's coming late
he's coming late so he's not here now
no represent of Langley I'm here in
Manchester and I'm alone
representative Stevens I am here now
schwa alone scroll down
representative Harper representative
Harper's muted
alright that better yes alright I am
Here I am currently alone but my wife
Brenda and my grandson's got may come in
and out of the room represented Sylvia I
the clerk is here on for the time being
represented Gordon representative
chandran I'm present I am in Seabrook
outside the town library and the wind by
myself thank you
Paul am I supposed to report record
where they are or just that they're in
attendance just that they're in
attendance Thank You representative
Griffin you're muted Barbara okay I'm
present alone in Bedford representative
MacLean I present my wife is present as
well yes with wife I guess I put in here
I don't know what I did a job my
representative Alexander I'm here I'm in
Goffstown and my roommate is currently
not in the room but she might be in an
out her name's Jessica and just if
you're on it this time I'm putting you
in as along okay so this what I had here
is a roll call sheet which is what Paul
sent me so I'm not sure how to handle
this but I think you tell me Paul will
check in with you and Jennifer will
check in with you after the meeting what
to do with with the records so I guess
well
thank you very much for taking the role
and thank you all very very much for
doing this it is not the way we want to
meet but it's better than not meeting
and not attending to our legislative
responsibilities the matter before the
committee today is House bill 1642 and
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative hopper you're on mute
again Paul I mean Gary there you go yeah
it automatically mutes me and then so i
okay so anyway I'm unmuted we are the
second committee on this bill and so the
house is already passed
sorry passed it so what the bill
basically does is make it illegal for
any state agency police station police
state police local police from using
facial recognition software to track
people and I think it's entirely
consistent with our recent
constitutional amendment that passed by
80% of the New Hampshire residents which
was a right to privacy oh yeah I'm
representing Hillsborough County - where
endearing I forgot at that so so
basically to me
it's very very fundamental that people
have a right to be secure wherever
they're going that they're not being
observed by officials by police or
anybody else
and or not anybody else by police
specifically by the state and so we're
playing catch-up in in 1928 there was a
case that went to the United States
Supreme Court and if I could read my own
writing I tell you I think it's
olmstead it was on sted case where I
believe those police were using
wiretapping to catch a criminal and that
went to the United States Supreme Court
the Supreme Court said well you're not
really violating the Fourth Amendment
because there you weren't actually
intruding on their papers or in their
building or anything else so the Supreme
Court said that that was okay and I
think any rational person today realizes
that tapping people's private
conversation is absolutely a violation
of their fundamental right to be secure
maybe not specifically in their papers
but still as it's a security issue so it
took about six years until the United
States Congress stepped up to the plate
and made that illegal wiretapping and
wiretapping to me is a good example of
what we're trying to do here
obviously in wiretapping if police were
able to tap all all the phones and all
the cell phones anytime they felt like
it I am quite positive the police could
solve a lot more crime cases and I am
absolutely positive if they could use
facial recognition software along with
cameras on every street corner they
could catch a lot more criminals but the
the fundamental question to me in
regards to this bill is how much Liberty
are you willing to concede so the police
can catch more criminals and to me I
don't think it's a it's a fair trade-off
I don't think as I'm walking down the
street the police should be able to
collect that image of me and compare it
electronically with something else and
no Gary Harper's walking down Elm Street
Manchester at any given time I don't
think it's any of their business where
I'm walking in any given time unless I'm
in in the unless I'm committing a crime
in which case they have other means by
which to catch me for doing that so
that's I'm not going to belabor this
because it's too
it's too tedious to do this on this way
I really like talking you guys and at
the meeting so that's basically it it
just if I think we can see where this
issue would go if left unchecked all you
have to do is look at places like China
right now and they have facial
recognition software they can actually
recognize people even if they're wearing
a mask
they keep constant tabs on all their
citizens they get millions and millions
of cameras all over China and you have
no liberty at all in China and and I I
want to make sure we never get there
and that's that's that's all I got
Thanks thank you very much
representative will you be willing to
answer any questions from your fellow
committee members yes
representative burrows
can you hear me now yes if I can just
butt in I apologized just so you know
we've got to take time to unmute you so
just kind of look at that little red
symbol or icon and you'll see when
you're ready to go okay so you'll do
that okay represent a 'king my question
represented hopper um it was interesting
that you brought up China because
there's a case that just came out in the
news today where there was a kidnapping
in China 32 years ago and they use
facial recognition technology to
identify the person who's now 32 years
old and to help solve the crime so if
this was implemented in the United
States would would that prohibit us from
being able to accomplish the same kind
of thing and would it mean that that
that case would have gone unsolved
Jennifer could you are you represented
Harper please yes yes that would go
unsolved the that's why I'm saying it's
a trade off if we allowed the police to
wiretap for the last 80 years or
whatever 100 years there's a lot of
crimes that they could have solved had
they been allowed to just tap every
conversation we've ever had so yes
there's a there's a lot of crimes that
would have been able to be prevented or
solved with facial recognition software
it's just a fundamental question of
whether you're willing to concede that
much Liberty for that much security it's
a trade off and I think the people of
New Hampshire a few years ago clearly
said 80% of them that they believe they
have a right to privacy so I think yes
that you could have solved that crime
but I don't believe the trade-off is is
fair if I can interrupt for just one
moment
representative Kenny has
arrived and the clerk should I guess
technically call on him to report that
he's here so I've Kurt if can it well /
and Kenny could be unmuted
representative Kenny could you report
where you are and whether you're alone
yes hello everyone I apologize for being
tardy I'm in my apartment in Durham um
and I am alone thank you thank you very
much now
representative Alexander has a question
for representative Harper good thank you
madam chair and thank you represent
hopper for taking my questions so I have
really two if that's okay
when reading the text of the bill it
says it's only a state or like
government entity is that correct yeah
okay and if I can follow up like why was
there any consideration to like Dan even
private entities from using the software
I think I I didn't consider it because
that's a private company and I don't
think the state has any right to
interfere with them I mean if Walmart
wants to use facial recognition software
so that when you walk in there they can
send you a text that their fishing
equipment is on sale that's that's kind
of intrusive but it's up to them okay
thank you representative al Schiller
you thank you for taking my question so
I understand what you're saying when you
know there are trade-offs and I don't
know that have had the trade-offs then
put so specifically everyone would agree
nor I do I think that 80% of the people
who voted for the constitutional
amendment would necessarily consider
this to be a logical next step there has
been just I know that representative
burrows talked about a case in China and
I'm very interested in that but I would
like to bring up a case in the United
States and just last August in New York
police were able to use facial
recognition to track down an accused
rapist and apprehend him within 24 hours
of an attack that he perpetrated at
knifepoint and so if for instance that
same perpetrator were to cross borders
in trying to evade law enforcement and
were to say come to New Hampshire then I
think what you're I think what this bill
would be saying is that we would not be
able to use those tools to apprehend
this person and I'm concerned that there
are already
facial-recognition being used for
instance in social media that law
enforcement uses right now and I'll give
you a specific example is that when
children are being abused sexually and
physically as part of you know
for-profit and that is something that
happens with regularity documented on
for instance pornhub which has offered
all kinds of free incentives here in the
in the states during this kovat 19
quarantine time
they actually broadcast video where you
can ask for someone to abuse a child in
front of the camera and the National
centers for Missing and Exploited
Children and our New Hampshire I catch
are able to use clues from those videos
and hopefully facial recognition if
screenshots are posted on social media
and it would be it's hard to imagine
that someone would do that but they do
to identify the children the location
and who the perpetrators are and I I
don't I would absolutely not support
that being a trade-off for hampering
investigations with a really really
important tool and on page two of the
bill in line lines one through three I'm
really really uncomfortable with
particularly line two data or
information in violation of this
subdivision shall be considered
unlawfully obtained and shall be
irretrievably deleted from any document
in possession of the state or any court
file or filing upon discovery I know
that as an advocate for victims of crime
to find out that the state would be in
the position of having to destroy
potential leads and evidence against a
perpetrator would be a crushing crushing
blow and I think that while I understand
some of the motivations for this
legislation the way that this is written
out instead throws every opportunity to
use this tool appropriately with just
throwing the tool away altogether
representative Harper do you want to
reply yes I do
so I I understand that I if years ago
I've filed bill my still on your on okay
so sorry about the interruption so years
ago when I first became was in the
legislature I passed bills to help
victim of victims of sexual abuse having
things happen in my own family I'm
acutely aware of the problem but you
could get using your same argument you
could go one step further I believe it
was Bill Gates was on a TED talk spoke
of electronically chipping people and in
doing so you'd be able to you know keep
track of where they were all the time
you would be able to find you would know
if somebody had had a had Cove in
nineteen and whether or not they could
freely go to another country because
they had shots for it and then if
everybody was chipped you would
absolutely know where everybody was at
all times and if a child was abducted
you could actually track who they were
with just before the abduction and where
they were once they were abducted so
there are tools to make sure that bad
things never happen again
and facial recognition software is one
of those tools to keep everybody safe
but my my threshold the way I look at
things is I try because we were our as
legislators most of us are old enough to
see the winds of politics switch back
and forth Gerry rapidly and people get
elected that we're just surprised even
got elected yet almost instantaneously
the people are very fickle and will just
kick the bums out and hire and hire new
people at a at a moment's notice and in
doing so the possibility of getting
somebody in office
it wants to abuse these tools that we
now are
would be using for good against us is
very very possible and so on on tools
that the government has access to I
always think of you know wwhd what would
Hitler do what would Hitler do with
those tools if he were elected as
remember he was elected in in Germany
and German people were not stupid people
they are very bright people and so when
we allow police to access all these
tools facial recognition software video
cameras everywhere microchips yes it
would keep us safer but how much Liberty
are you willing to concede for that and
to me we it's better to stop it before
it gets to a point where it's abused and
then then wait until afterwards because
then it's too late the chair recognizes
representative Woodberry to be followed
by representative MacLean and then
representative birch representative
Woodbury thank you thank you madam chair
Thank You representative Harper for
taking my question I am is still unmuted
can you hear me yes okay you you you
explain to us that this bill is
necessary because it's very much like a
bill which should have taken place 100
years ago to prevent wiretapping I
wonder placing placing this bill in the
wiretapping context wouldn't it be more
accurate to say that instead of
preventing surveillance what it actually
does is to prevent a tool useful to make
surveillance sensible and wouldn't that
be the essential equivalent of saying in
the wiretap situation not that you
couldn't wiretap but that you couldn't
use voice recognition software to
establish whose voice it was so that
instead of preventing instead of
preventing the evil of unregulated
surveillance this bill simply limits the
ability to make a sensible use of that I
guess I've said enough I hope you're
gonna respond representative hopper yeah
I kind of get the analogy but to me I
think be using that same analogy the
police can still wiretap but they have
to get a warrant to do so and but facial
recognition software my understanding is
it's it's kind of like the same analogy
would mean that they could wiretap
everybody and then only use that part of
a criminal that was talking on a phone
in a court case
so because the facial recognition kind
of is too broad a spectrum so it can it
just identifies everybody as they're
walking down the street so I think
that's the difference a wiretap is that
specific is targeted and that's why you
can get a get a warrant for a wiretap on
Gary Harper's phone because it's
specific and it's a specific crime but I
don't think they shall recognition
software works like that and I could be
totally wrong but I don't believe so so
I think it's I think the analogy falls
short Thank You representative mcclain
thank you madam chair can you hear me
okay absolutely
all right great representative Haas for
thank you for taking my questions so I
just kind of I'm going to try to get it
all in because of the muting and the
unmuting so I'll do the best job that I
can but to kind of follow up on a
representative Alexander's tread
we did get some testimony from the New
Hampshire Association of Chiefs of
Police and I think the bill addresses
the bulk of the concerns
put forth by the Bedford police chief
but item three in his submitted
testimony was that the bill as written
would not allow law enforcement to use a
store camera to identify the subject and
you were you are talking about you know
that a Walmart camera would be okay so
but this bill as it's written I think
that while Walmart would be able to take
or the the store would be able to tape
or I can even have a camera like one of
those ring cameras on my door the police
would not be able to make use of it and
so I think you know as I look at the
actual bill itself line 16 it says that
they cannot use any facial recognition
system so I think as written it doesn't
allow you to use even the private stuff
so I guess my question would be would
you be open to modifying maybe line 16
on the bill to say any government
operated facial recognition system
because if somebody broke into my house
I would certainly want to be able to
give the police the data from my ring
camera or something to help them find
out who broke into my house so I guess
that was my question that just would
welcome your thoughts on that
representative Harper yeah I believe I
understand the concept
I believe the previous committee fixed
that but I'll let them speak to that
because I believe the my understanding
is the facial recognition software
is a technological ability to look at
that picture and digitally identify the
person and compared to other photographs
whereas what you're talking about is I
get videotape chocolate lifting again in
me and Walmart and they use just my
picture which somebody says oh yeah
that's Gary Harper that's okay but using
it digitally to identify me
compared to say for instance my driver's
license that would be illegal under this
so I don't I don't think it prohibits I
think that is is is unfounded but I will
let represent and the Schmidt talk about
that when he gets on is he I think the
previous committee dealt with that
Thank You representative birch thank you
madam chair Thank You representative I
want to go back to the concerns raised
by representative all Schiller because I
share those concerns I've been involved
in my past life with both training and
actual legal work representing
individuals charged with child
pornography and similar offenses and
what I know in general is when a
computer is seized from a suspect and
there are images on that computer let's
say it's a it's a naked person and a
suggestive pose there is a big
difference in terms of consequences
whether that individual is let's say 20
years old or that individual is 14 years
old and one of the ways that crucial
question is answered is the effort to
determine who is that person in that
image and the way that is done is to run
that image through databases of known
Exploited Children and when a match is
reached and you know the age and
identity of that person then you can
easily determine the age of the the
person involved so that is crucial to
the apprehension of child predators in
fact Interpol's child sexual
exploitation database which again would
be unavailable
for use it would be in the band category
has more than 1.5 million images of
Exploited Children and has helped
identify over 19,000 IDEX ployed
children this bill would simply make
that impossible and I'm wondering if
that was taken into consideration
representative hopper yeah Thank You
representative birch I don't think that
was necessarily specifically taken into
consideration but I think my my previous
answer still sit stands as to yes you
there are many crimes you could solve by
constant monitoring monitoring of
everybody but how much Liberty are you
willing to concede to get there and to
me this is facial recognition software
there's I was just reading it in another
report this morning out of MIT and they
referred to a Italian criminologist I
believe who has determined that through
facial recognition software he's pretty
confident he can determine who is going
to be a criminal because in his words
criminals have eight like features so I
don't know I just it did the technology
itself is is frightening to me and it's
it's it scares me for my children and
grandchildren as to how much Liberty
they're gonna lose just for that that
those cases where we can all see why
this this technology would be helpful
but I think long term it is a is a
threat to people's Liberty so I still I
mean I'm willing to accept amendments to
it or whatever to get it passed but I
but it's not I don't I don't think
there's anything wrong with the bill
itself anyway Thanks thank you are you
still willing to take more questions
yeah okay
next is representative Hagen
okay now I'm unmuted sorry about that
yes I did I remember a conversation I
had when would the bill was about to
come to the house with the Manchester
Police Chief and I guess what he said is
the same as what the Bedford Police
Chief said pretty much but he he he
pointed out that like you know there's
cameras all over the place almost all of
which have can be used for facial
recognition now all kinds of you
mentioned Walmart for example with all
kinds of other businesses and private
individuals and they do use that video
all the time to crime and he said if we
pass this bill as is and everybody would
be able to use this technology except
the police force so he found that
objectionable of course and I that is
that your question representative
Corrigan yes I guess wherever comment of
the would you believe so and so that was
a someone say I've heard that from other
police officers other than one from
Bedford emailed us Thank You Jenny
popper yeah yeah I heard that same thing
too and I think if you folks remember
earlier this year we had a Manchester
policeman say basically saying that
we're talking about surveilled video
surveillance of the streets in
Manchester and he conceded that you know
if he had his way and had the money he
has cameras everywhere and yes we could
have surveillance cameras everywhere and
and we could have facial recognition
software so that everybody coming in or
out of a church or a synagogue could be
recorded and police would know exactly
who was going in or out and if they
exceeded the ten person limit and that
would that would be very effective law
enforcement but to is to represent an
Oregon's question
yes Walmart can have this technology yes
Sears good I guess we don't have scares
anywhere but the mall can have this
technology but the fact of the matter is
Walmart and Sears can't arrest me
Walmart and Sears can't investigate me
for crime or possibly arrest me or sir
you know be motivated to keep track of
my whereabouts and things like that
those those private entities can use
this software whatever they they want
it's whether or not we want the state
which has so much resources and so much
power to have that additional power to
keep track of its citizens
representative Gordon wait wait
representative Gordon you haven't been
unmuted yet wait trying I'm not sure
what's taking so long
can you unmute unmute on your own screen
there we go good representative Gordon
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Potter for taking the
questions I I think I had maybe have two
questions in the comments the first
question I have goes to the issue I
think that's been raised by other
committee members and that is that it
seems to me and I think you've
acknowledged the fact that facial
recognition could serve a valuable prize
what you said is on balance it's better
to be committed in certain circumstances
in order under the Constitution as well
and people's homes can be searched for
example but there are exceptions and
specifically exceptions made so that the
police can get a warrant and if they do
later to go to a court could be
committed they could to undertake
activities with privacy and I guess the
question did you consider it putting
this bill together that law enforcement
will be able to get warrants in order to
use that's a good point I don't know how
you how you I would be certainly a
amendable to an amendment did that allow
that but I'm not sure how technically
you get there so I don't know enough
about it to know
that that's doable but if it is that
seems totally reasonable and it might
help with representative all shall it
serve and representative birches issues
with the bill too but I don't know how
you get there
Thank You representative dilorenzo Inc
if it take my question representative
Harper
are you aware of any New Hampshire state
agencies for departments law enforcement
or otherwise who currently use a
spectrum recognition technology no I'm
not
representative Griffin Thank You
representative Harper section 2 of the
bill makes a change to motor vehicle
statutes line 22 page 2 provides that
there's a modification to a section of
driver's licenses and it deletes the
words for purposes of this chapter in
that particular provision there is a
specific reference to the department
being prohibited from using facial
recognition technology in connection
with taking or retaining any photograph
or digital image I would like to know
what the purpose of deleting that is and
I expect the answer is so that it
doesn't keep it as to the driver's
license chapter it would be under this
new provision that you're providing but
when you answer it could you explain how
you balance that with the fact that the
motor vehicle statute has a specific
provision that allows individuals to
make the choice
to not have their image retained in the
motor vehicle database representative
hopper am I still am i unmuted you're
ready to go okay I don't have a good
answer for that I just I was reading
over the bill again today and I didn't
pick up on that so I I'm choking on that
one representative Jan I didn't realize
it was gonna pop up and say do you want
on you
so Gary thanks for taking my question
last year I was 20 18 we had a bill come
through a concurrent resolution came
through the House and Senate was passed
on to the voters to amend the
Constitution and I just want to read
that amendment that was made it added
the words an individual's right to live
free from government intrusion in
private or personal information is a
natural essential and inherent so we've
had a few bills this year that seek to
define what that meant I'm assuming your
bill that you're proposing here whether
it's amended or not is in fact defining
that inherent right to privacy that's in
the Constitution rather than allowing
court cases to go to a court to be
adjudicated to further define this
amendment made for the Constitution is
that correct yeah yeah thank you for the
question yeah
if basically the the amendment that we
just passed by 80% of the population
basically I think the voters of New
Hampshire my constituents said that they
believe they have a right to privacy
without government intrusion and I think
this is just putting I think meat on the
bones
somebody phrased it earlier this year
thank you thank you I have three people
who want to speak a 2nd time
representatives burrows aisle chiller
and Gordon would it be all raw and birch
would it be all right if we put those on
hold and hear from the chair of the
subcommittee and EDA perhaps or would
you rather I continue with taking
questions from the committee who would
you like to recognize representative
well I would like to recognize if
there's no objection to recognize
Peterson I would like to recognize Peter
Schmidt me just a minute okay
representative Schmidt I'm here good go
for it okay well I certainly appreciated
the colloquy that I've been listening to
since the end of the roll call anyway
excellent questions that by and large
the EDA committee did not consider
because it's not part of our expertise
and purview so we were looking at the
aspects of the bill to which we were
invited to participate we heard very
excellent an expert testimony with
regard to the dangers of effectively of
facial recognition technology so there
are several aspects to discuss here
first of all this bill as I think has
been remarked on doesn't do anything to
private businesses right to employ
cameras in their stores and and we know
that they they many of the stores do
virtually all of my
probably I don't look in every store I
go into it to see whether cameras up on
the ceiling or in the corners but figure
it's a fairly safe assumption that we
are videotaped or photographed and in a
number of establishments that this bill
doesn't affect that secondly one of the
one of the aspects that was troubling to
us with regard to facial recognition
technology is that it's not the same for
everybody if you're a young white male
the chances of accurate depiction are
pretty good from there on up in age or
away from white Caucasian members of
society the quality of the reproduction
or of the recognition deteriorates is
decreasing anyway that's an issue that
people won't want to give some
consideration to because to the degree
that either somebody is recognized as
being somebody that they aren't or that
the person who is that person is not
recognized that's not a good thing in
terms of being a reliable resource for
law enforcement or any other purpose so
that that that's one of the
considerations but but facial
recognition basically and that's why we
switched because the original bill is
you probably have seen talked about
facial surveillance systems and we've
seen that in the case of the tsarnaev
brothers the marathon Marathon bombers
imagine virtually all of us saw the
footage where the two brothers came
marching into the you know focal range
of the of the camera you could see them
and then they disappeared from that
cameras purview and it was picked up and
the next cameras purview virtually
seamlessly so you saw many of the stores
on Newbury
think had such capabilities so and you
could see no they had the pressure
cookers in there in their backpacks or
at least very large bulges and their
backpacks so here the question was not
Mizzou bombers that case was made pretty
quickly but the question was who are
these people so facial surveillance is
very valuable for capturing actions such
as shoplifting or robbery or whatever
but then the question is who is this
individual or who are these individuals
if it's more than what and then the
reality is then the police have to go
trying to figure out now who done it but
who are the people and that that is one
of the advantages of facial recognition
technology is that a the images are
duplicate our sorry our digitalized
and in that manner they can be
immediately compared to the database
that exists everywhere in government's a
la fingerprints okay so to the degree
that the that the that the then the
digitalized images can be compared and
and and the the database of course would
have a name associated with that
identity with that individual and
thereby you could almost instantaneously
to degree that the tech technology is as
accurately doing this already referenced
it's it's its flaws at the moment but to
the degree that is recognized
immediately it's a tremendous law
enforcement tool there's no question
about that
and I really welcome this committee's
expertise in dealing with the issues
that have been raised a number of time
you know in questions to represent
so thank you thank you very much
representative Schmidt representative
McGuire do you have anything that you
want to add to what's been said so far
representative acquire was on the
subcommittee that dealt with this bill
in edn a yes madam chair thank you very
much
one thing that I got from your questions
and comments is there is a bit of
confusion between the idea of a
photograph and a facial recognition
system there this bill does not ban
anyone including the police from taking
pictures of people whether they're
suspect or they're just walking down Elm
Street in Manchester what it does is
prevent them from maintaining a database
of pictures of faces with the Associated
data and then using a computer to
compare them if they want to get a photo
from Walmart of a suspected shoplifter
and they show it to the local police and
they and the local police says oh yeah
that's Gary hopper we know all about him
or that they the owner of a store that
was robbed looked at and said yeah that
guy came in last he comes in twice a
week.i I don't know his name but he
lives around here somewhere
people are still allowed to look at
pictures and recognize them what we're
prohibiting with this bill is the
development of a database of pictures of
people and the and their identities and
so that is why we chose to ban the DMV
from you from doing it because they have
a database of pictures most people keep
their pictures on file and that contains
a great deal of information like your
name your address your birth date some
of them still probably have social
security numbers you don't want that
data stolen or used and so this bill
does not prohibit them from keeping a
database it keeps them from using it in
a facial
recognition system which is a different
matter entirely
and as representative Schmidt said right
now facial recognition has a lot of
false positives and a lot of false
negatives it is not that useful unless
you have a very large database and you
have pictures of the people a large
database of the people you want to
compare to and nobody in New Hampshire
as far as we know has that the bill
specifically exempts law enforcement
cooperation with federal agencies that
have used facial recognition and in fact
it would allow cooperation with other
agencies as long as we don't use the the
facial recognition ourselves we could
still send photos from iraf a robbery in
Salem to the Massachusetts police and if
they say without telling us they have
used facial recognition
oh that's Joe Blow from Lawrence will
arrest him and send him to you that's
that was what we thought would be the
appropriate use is that we use the
pictures we have and we use people to
recognize them but we do not allow law
enforcement to maintain and use a
database of pictures there are that it
would be possible if there were specific
cases where someone wanted to allow that
for example that database of abuse
children might be allowable but our
victims of crimes whatever but right now
we don't want to maintain a general
database of people partly their privacy
and freedom partly because it would
generate too many false positives and
not have the right kinds of
ah sorry distract that and it would all
having such a database would also be a
major incentive for a lot of people and
agencies to invade our privacy by
putting up for putting up cameras and
more places than there are now and
that's something that I'm concerned with
as long as you can you only use a photo
for to have a policeman look at it or an
individual for that identity it's
limited and how much invasion of your
privacy they can do is limited if you
can use a database of everybody in the
country and and instantaneously say well
it's one of this dozen people that's an
incentive for a lot of people and
agencies to go out and put cameras in
more places and I don't believe that's
something that that we want to have an
answer and I'll be glad to answer any
questions are there any questions for
representative McGuire I know you have
general things any questions
specifically for representative McGuire
representative Woodbury has a question
okay yep okay this actually is a
question which might be answered either
by representative Schmidt or
representative McGuire but I'd like to
know in the edn a hearings whether or
not there was a discussion comparing the
accuracy of facial recognition software
and the accuracy of in-person human to
human identification which we have known
is very fallible over the years and I
just wonder if there was a discussion as
to which which came out on top yes we
did talk a little bit about that we
didn't ourselves analyze it because
we're not experts we had some people
from the industry and some experts from
UNH working with us and in general
people are better at facial recognition
than
machines and this that may not be that
way for long but right now they are
particularly with things like if you're
dealing with people with beards you're
dealing with older people you're dealing
with non-caucasians you're dealing with
children or if you've changed your
hairdo or got new glasses
we people are best better at dealing
with at them than machines
representative birch did you have a
question for McGwire or Schmidt yes I
would follow up with representative why
I'm concerned representative about your
last statement I've spent decades with
people who look through mug shot books
at picture after picture after the first
20 or 30 or 50 mug shots they look at
their level of identification is almost
nil and lineups are notorious for
similar problems so we know that people
identification and there are hundreds
and hundreds of studies to show people
identification of pictures and lineups
are one of the largest contributors to
false convictions that we have in this
country I have yet to see a single study
and I'm wondering if you have seen a
single study that supports a computer
going through five hundred mug shots is
less accurate than a person going
through five hundred mug shots because I
simply don't believe that I haven't seen
such a study exactly and as I said we
didn't do that sort of study we don't
have that information but the people who
who were testified at our subcommittee
he work sessions were positive that
facial recognition systems had a very
high false positive rate they are not as
but and that's something that
we need to deal with we need to realize
when we're dealing with these systems
thank you
I've looked at the attendees and I can't
find whomever is on this list
representing the police chiefs could you
indicate who you are I think that would
be Beth's argent is that correct yes
that would be good she is here I can't
allow her to talk okay um you know yes
yeah yes you're on now high rep I
represented Smith it's Beth's urgent
good old steamed up okay can I pass the
baton to chief goldstein chief goldstein
is on the line and prepared to speak and
answer correctly certainly right well
we'd love texting identified so you have
to let us know who he is
Jen how how can I let what do you need
his what is his phone number yeah I need
his the last four digits of his phone
number okay gotcha
okay it should be nine seven eight - I
do not see okay hold on let me let me
just text him
oh he's sending me a note I'll get you
that he says I he can see you hold on
Oh hold on he's gonna send me the number
unless if he's online
Oh could pn6
603 eight-six but you said he could see
us so that means he was connected online
is that right yes
is he guests Gao Gao baby let me let me
ask him
why don't we see if that can be sorted
out I don't want to take you all our
time and maybe Brad can help go through
those phone numbers to see yes you can
email me okay okay I really didn't want
them next okay I think what happens is
the phone number that is the phone
number that they were told to dial not
necessarily what their phone number is
because that's happened before and we do
have what four people here who or five
who have phone numbers so that's not
much help okay
the chair recognizes Jean Ruska hi
everyone can you hear me all right
yes good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to chime in I just want to
underscore a couple points that one has
been raised in a couple that haven't I
would just underscore a representative
McGuire's concerns about reliability we
do not consider facial recognition a
reliable technology and I'll note that
the government agency that's actually in
charge of evaluating new technologies
NIST has also ruled that this technology
is not reliable it's one of the reasons
that certain companies are not using it
right now because of the rate of false
positives particularly because of the
rate of false positives amongst people
of color and I'll just note we know
people of color are already
disproportionately subjected to the
criminal legal system so we're
particularly concerned about using a
technology that has that same disparity
in its ability to identify people but I
also
go back a little bit and kind of explain
why we support starting with a
prohibition on this technology we have
come before this committee before in
support of legislation that is trying to
create guardrails around a certain
technology or a certain procedure that's
already in robust use if you can
remember last year there was a bill
about DNA right and trying to create a
privacy guardrail around the existing
use of DNA and what we know is once a
technology is in rampant use it is
really really hard to restrict it it's
so hard if not impossible to put the
genie back in the bottle and our concern
is that this technology will become in
such robust use that when if we try and
go back afterwards and restrict it and
contain it it'll be next to impossible
and so the benefit for us with this bill
is you start with a prohibition I think
we fully expect that even as early as
next year you could see bills that come
in and try and create exceptions that
this legislature could consider on a
case-by-case basis
you start with a prohibition and then
allow people that come forward in a
transparent public manner where the
public can see how this technology might
get used the reliability of this
technology can be assessed and this
legislature then on a case-by-case basis
can create exceptions can allow the
technology whether it's with a warrant
whether it's specifically in cases of
lost children you can create those
exceptions but it's so much easier to
proactively do that on a case-by-case
basis going forward than it is trying to
establish privacy guardrails and
restrict a privacy technology once it's
already in robust use and I'll just note
the example of whether eyewitness
testimony is reliable or not
eyewitness testimony is unreliable which
is one of the reasons why it has taken
decades to try and establish very
specific procedures for how that process
is done this legislature actually
recently passed a bill
establishing guidelines on how
eyewitness identification is to be done
because there are ways to make it more
reliable than not there are no such
guidelines right now with facial
recognition there are no restrictions
there are no regulations as to how to
use it properly or how to use it
improperly how to make it more reliable
it's it's no-man's land it's kind of a
free-for-all right now with this
technology and so again the benefit of
starting with a prohibition is you
create you start with 100% civil liberty
protection and then you allow this
legislature to consider next year ways
that this technology can be used and as
you consider that you can then establish
procedures for how it can be used if
it's a warrant what needs to be shown
how do you ensure that if a warrant is
granted that by standards are not
captured while you're trying to narrow
in on a particular person and so right
now the question was asked of whether
there's any New Hampshire state agency
that uses this technology and to be
honest I'm not sure if there is because
I'm not convinced that if a police
department decided to use this
technology that they would notify the
public we know that there are cases
where law enforcement use technologies
that that where the public is not
notified where it's actually kept
confidential that law enforcement is
using that technology and so again I
know I'm sounding like a broken record
here but if you start with a prohibition
and allow this legislative body to
consider individual uses going forward
the public is notified that is a very
transparent process you have public
hearings the public is notified that
this technology will be used they are
allowed to chime in and speak up on
whether they are comfortable with this
technology being used right now I expect
law enforcement are actually talking
with private companies who want to sell
them this technology but we don't know
that we're not a part of that
conversation and we won't know the day
that the technology is adopted and so
for us it's not that we're looking to
prohibit this technology completely
forever with no exceptions the goal is
to start with a prohibition so
that we can then have an informed
transparent conversation going forward
about how maybe this technology can be
used in limited capacities with very
specific established procedures and
guardrails and so those are the points I
wanted to raise I'm happy to take
questions represented Burroughs sorry
right there yes um thank you for taking
the question I was wondering if you
might be able to respond I actually to a
conversation that I had with the chief
of police of Jackson New Hampshire who
felt that the scientific efficacy
validity and reliability of technology
is something that should be handled in
the court system rather than by the
legislature and he he gave the example
of dog sniffing dogs you know some of
them are more reliable than others based
on on the training that they get there's
also been cases involving blood spatter
and depending on who the expert is and
and and also technology around bite
marks so I'm wondering if you could
respond to the comments that he made
which I thought were pretty interesting
thank you for that question
representative that I actually strongly
disagree with that I I can't imagine
that courts want to be the decider about
whether technology is reliable and
judges are not technological experts and
obviously representatives aren't
necessarily technological experts or not
but to me it is actually the
Legislature's job to kind of decide this
sort of issue about whether certain
technology should be used and and
whether if they are allowed to be used
what the procedures are I think this
goes to a concern that representative
hopper raised that the voters approved a
very very broad constitutional amendment
and I think one of the reasons you're
seeing privacy bills is that voters have
concerned and legislators have concerns
about the court being left to try and
figure out what part one article 2 B
means I actually think it is the
responsibility of the ledges
later to flesh out that constitutional
amendment and to make a decision about
what privacy rights mean it when it
comes to informational privacy like this
and so as a voter and as a somebody who
cares deeply about privacy I'm very
nervous about simply deferring to the
courts to make really complex decisions
about whether technology is reliable or
not they'll have to make case-by-case
decisions obviously but I strongly
encourage this legislature to be
proactive in considering individual
privacy considerations because I would I
would like to see part one article to be
fleshed out and statute where rather
than waiting for the courts to do it in
response to you know whatever random
case may come their way
thank you very much
Jane have we been able to sort out the
problem with the police chief we are
still working on it whether he's going
to file a Joe I do have I believe that
it's the name David I just had him on
the phone they believe he is David and
if you're okay with it I can go ahead
and just give the permission to talk and
I think that absolutely all right here
we go we'll see if it's the correct
person they became to you can you talk
hello
it is not me okay different Davis all
right not the right one all right I will
keep working on it my apologies okay
we can't just click on these telephone
numbers and see who's on each one of
them there were only what we could do is
if you are chief goldstein calling from
one from a telephone if you could press
star nine to raise your hand we'll
recognize you
thank you
I don't see anyone
[Music]
well this concerns me because I think
it's important that we do hear from the
individual who's representing the police
chiefs I think it's an important part of
of what we're trying to do let me then
go back to the people who had I hope
you're all sort trying to sort that out
let me go back to the people who had
questions ah
wait was that someone no representative
al Schiller did you have something you
wanted to say I'm sorry just a moment
thank you
thank you so my question goes back to
representative Schmidt and
representative McGuire who were on the
subcommittee and I'm curious about
whether you had during the
subcommittee's time together
have you considered some of the programs
that we are currently using for instance
the VIP the victim identification
program that is the program that we are
using right now to combat child
exploitation and was there consideration
made for for instance the sex offender
registry or for any of most-wanted lists
that are done by municipalities who you
know put up pictures of people who have
committed you know who are you know
known to law enforcement and they need
to let the couplet let the people know
that there's someone at large who's a
danger so had the committee considered
those three things that are being used
right now and was it the committee's
intention to throw away
this tool altogether and only bring it
back as an exception to a rule or you
know had that had it not been phrased in
quite that way
are we gonna direct representing mcguire
with that representative mcguire or
schmidt I believe both were on that
subcommittee so I'm open to either I
don't see representative Schmidt on my
screen anymore but I think he's still
here okay are they still here yes okay
Pete representative McGuire Schmidt can
you answer that represented McGuire
recognized yes I can she answer your
question represented all show or no we
do not consider those specific I'm not
still muted again now we hear you we
hear you we are not as familiar with
them as you are because we're obviously
a different committee that's why we're
both committees are at it we have no
this bill would not prohibit anyone
posting information or pictures of
people they are suspicious of
most-wanted lists could could still be
posted at the post office or Town Hall
or whatever what it prohibits is having
an automatic system that would compare
those pictures to some other database
it's not the use of photos of suspects
or even of convicted sex offenders or
whatever that is the issue it's the
automatic matching of some photo of
someone instantly from Stan's with that
database that the bill would prohibit so
I don't believe it would affect any of
those systems you don't you mentioned or
as they are in use right now although
I'm not sure because I'm not familiar
with the details
Thank You representative Gordon
representative Gordon I think and I
think representative McGuire could
answer the question perhaps but I think
the the the problem I'm having is that
getting back to the constitutional
amendment the recently adopted and
defining crisis because it seems to me
that facial recognition is used as we've
all been describing is used today by
police to identify people because that's
the way we identify people by virtue of
their faces and we do that humanely with
our eyes and the issue here is issue of
not whether or not we can identify
people it's the use of technology to do
that in the law we the standard that's
constantly used is expectation of
privacy when people are out in public
and they make themselves available in
public they have no expectation of
privacy so I'm trying to figure out how
we apply the standard of expectation of
privacy to a facial recognition system
and in that if people are out in public
I'm not sure that they have an
expectation of privacy I think what
really the bill gets said is we're just
offended that technology is used being
used to identify us and I and I think
represented McGuire you specifically
address that by saying hey what we
really want to do with prohibit
databases and so I I guess I'm trying to
figure out how the legal standards in
this particular case would be applied
and whether we're really talking about
privacy or technology
representative DeLorenzo I'm just
quickly I'm sorry to interrupt but we do
have the chief on the line now all right
if it's all right with everyone let's
hear him okay just a moment
chief goldstein yes did that work yes
Oh wonderful good afternoon everybody
good afternoon we'd love to hear what
you have to say certainly and I
appreciate the opportunity as always I
must tell you though that as a police
officer I'm very worried about zoom
because I've been in a lot of houses and
I'm wondering if I violated the Fourth
Amendment over the last few weeks the
number of houses I've been in that's a
joke I'm sorry well I I knew you meant
it as a joke but we're kind of or not in
an in an entertaining mood i think chief
broflovskis remarks pretty well
underscore how the Chiefs feel about
this I took some notes on some of the
comments that I did hear and I'd like to
address just a couple of those for the
committee's benefit first and foremost
to use wiretapping as an analogous
situation is really well left-field
wiretapping and since the beginning
quite frankly has always been very very
regulated by the courts in fact it's
probably harder to get a wiretap warrant
than a search warrant today and as an
old-time undercover guy who did a lot of
wiretaps I'm very familiar with that so
I don't think that that particular
argument holds a great deal of of
credence relative to this counsel
brought up a very interesting point
about starting from a particular level
where everything is prohibited and then
we work from there we on the other hand
we look at it just the opposite way we
feel that by giving us the opportunity
to do this
as case law has developed over time we
can certainly comply with that and we
know that that will happen so we're
looking at this kind of as a blank slate
if you will I understand that people
would like data-driven information I
realize that there is not a lot but I
will offer you this and this is from
your own organization this is from a
National Conference of State Legislators
and I quote most biometric systems have
a high accuracy rate more than 95
percent when matching a biometric
against a large database of biometrics
or against the originally enrolled
biometric and quite frankly the FBI
right now maintains a a repository of
over 70 2.6 million records that can be
accessed legally so I would offer that
to the committee as well so there is
some data that is being developed our
question really quite frankly is to have
an outright ban right now we feel is
inappropriate and that we can certainly
work on this with the committee and with
anybody else that's interested in trying
to design some a parameter in which we
can work and certainly to coin a phrase
that I've heard many many times over the
10 years that I've been coming to the
legislature this particular bill we feel
is not ready for primetime so we would
like like that to be considered as well
to exchange certain rights if you will
for the commission of crimes I would ask
the representative with all due respect
to go to the families of the 9/11
victims or go to the families of the
Marathon bombing victims and see how
they feel about that knowing how those
systems work what happened actually
being involved to some degree with those
and with individuals who were victims of
those particular situations certainly
they would not agree that that's a
trade-off and finally I would offer that
yes China does were China wants to do we
we certainly hear a great deal about
that in news today but I would also
refer you to England and Israel who have
been using these systems for quite a
period of time
and it's because of the Israeli system
that we were able to find the true
Marathon bombers as quickly as we did
and certainly I'm open to any questions
that the committee might have thank you
very much chief we're always happy to
hear from you thank you um okay
it I want to just stop for a minute and
take the committee's temperature we've
been at this for an hour and a half and
it is straining to try to go through
this process it's difficult without us
being in the same room and I'm
sympathetic to that I want a sense of
where you want to go there are a couple
of possibilities one is to keep on going
for a while today if we think we're
moving towards a point another is to see
if we can schedule another work session
and that is not in my control it's in
the control of the wonderful staff who
have have to do that we do have another
session scheduled which I had listed as
an executive session for May 28th which
is a week from Thursday I guess I want
to know whether we think that there is
any way that we can get to yes with
amendments I think it's clear we nobody
seems to want to get to yes without
amendments including the prime sponsor
or I will not even pretend that we can
that it would make any sense to do an
interim study
because there really aren't going to be
working in term studies this summer
so the choice that we have is basically
yes yes with an amendment or no and is
there some guidance I can get from you
as to how you want to proceed
perhaps I've already put out my request
through text to see if we could get
another meeting before the 28th but I
haven't gotten an answer so I don't know
a representative would Barry give me a
thumbs up okay Joanne yes I'd be glad to
give you a sense of my temperature on
this and I I'm not I'm not in favor of
this bill I'm not in favor of working
toward an amendment for it and I am in
favor of either ITL we're at the
appropriate time laying it on the table
and my reason is twofold first of all in
this in this time a sort of special time
that we have our ability to work is
severely compromised not only in point
of time but in point of efficiency and
ability to get together and really
communicate there is no particular need
to rush this bill through this is not a
bill that is on the forefront of
anybody's I mean it's certainly on the
forefront of that sponsors but it's
certainly not in the forefront of where
we're going it can certainly wait and it
can certainly be done in a good thorough
way there's nothing more clear to me
from this afternoon's conversation that
this bill is in total disarray and I
mean that
is is gently and as nicely to all
concerned as I possibly can express it
but we are not close to working this
thing out and it just seems to me that
it's not it's not fruitful to beat our
heads against the stone on this with the
limited time and resources that we have
now the second point that I want to get
to is that what we're dealing here with
is whether or not we will accept or
reject the simple element of science
this is not this bill has nothing to do
with whether or not there are more or
less cameras set up and more or less
miles of film taken of people walking
around the streets this is about the
science of what you do with that
information I want to contrast the
science of facial recognition with the
idea of somebody sitting in front of a
TV screen after an eight-hour shift and
making judgment about who's who we don't
know we have no way of knowing based on
the record we have in front of us who
who is better equipped to do that and we
aren't going to know that between now
and June 11th or whatever later date
this bill comes up
yeah I'm not I I listen to scientists I
I'm not a scientist I respect them if
this is a bill that can be made if this
is a science that can be made better so
be it fair enough
you certainly if you're going to use a
science you want it to be accurate I
don't I don't favor the idea of blanket
prohibition and then working against it
I think we can do this right the first
time we don't have to do it today and we
don't have to do it a week from today or
a month from today it can be done in a
regular business in the regular way when
we're all back to business as usual I
just want to end by saying I'm reminded
of the old maxim the Mary Mary in haste
repent at leisure and I
think we're in danger of marrying in
haste if we go just jam this thing
forward
as best we can so that's those are my
thoughts Thanks Thank You representative
a representative Bertrand thank you
madam chair
I'm an agreement with representative
Woodbury
I'm not going to repeat what he said
because better than I I do want to
observe just in passing since this
questions come up a couple times that
the most recent information from what's
referred to as NIST National Institute
of Standards and Technology has found
that the error rate is 0.08 percent in
the algorithm use as opposed to four
point one percent just a few years ago
so the accuracy of the system has just
skyrocketed courts have notoriously been
notoriously the wrong where courts
always pay attention to technology and
should it be admissible or should it not
be we have what's called the Dover test
courts routinely evaluate whether
technology is good technology or bad
that's what they do every day of the
week I the problem I have
which representative Woodbury didn't
mention is the difficulty built into
this bill with any further legislative
or court evaluation of facial
recognition technology should we pass
this bill there are two provisions one
provision says any evidence collected
relative to this program has to be
immediately destroyed and then further
commissioned say that no legislative
committee nor court can utilize any data
information or evidence derived from
facial recognition technology so
we wanted to evaluate two years from now
is this program a good program is it a
bad program how does it work how is it
not we're gonna have a hard time as a
legislative committee if this passes
being able to deal with any data so I
think this bill should be ITL and if
it's taken up next year then fine it's
also not an emergency covin related bill
which I think what we're supposed to be
trying to focus on on that last point I
guess I would like to disagree with you
and that is that I look back to what
happened after 9/11 and I look back to
the Patriot Act and I look back to how
many of our civil liberties were
willingly given up because of the
emergency of the moment and I believe
that we are in the same period where
many of our civil liberties are going to
be challenged whether it's with facial
recognition or something else they're
going to be challenged we're going to be
asked to agree to do things that
philosophically I find offensive and
then I actually think a number of you
would would find offensive and that was
why I thought it was very important that
the committee have a chance to look at
this bill and not because I knew where
we would come out but because of
believing that we have consistently
tried to be sensitive to our role to
respect civil rights and civil and civil
liberties I have listened carefully to
what everyone has said I believe the
exigencies of the time make it very very
difficult for us to find a way to thread
the needle to find what is the narrowest
protection that we could put in
legislation not to have it be too
expansive but but to have it important
and I don't
away for the committee to do that so
while I think this is the time and I
think the issue is incredibly important
and I thank the prime sponsor for
bringing the bill both through a DNA and
to us now I personally don't see a way
for the committee to get to yes and I
guess what I would we do have we do have
an executive session scheduled for 10
o'clock on the 28th and I'm going to
keep that because we're not voting today
what I would like to propose is that we
end this work session that if there are
individuals or a number of people on the
committee and those who aren't on the
committee who might want to but it would
not be people on the committee who would
submit an amendment to see if there is a
way that we could get to yes then this
gives you 10 days to do it to do an
amendment to propose to get to OLS and
time for them to do it and it might be
that with Gary and others we might be
able to find some small piece that makes
sense and so my proposal would be that
if the majority of the committee agree
we end the work session now we come back
at 10:00 a.m. on the 28th for an
executive session where we may or may
not have an amendment to consider does
that make sense to the group can you
just you know indicate
I don't see thank you Gary I was looking
for that I don't see another way and I
don't know if we would have had a
different outcome if we weren't sitting
in 25 different locations without the
ability to see each other to be in the
same room to check body language to be
informal all of that is missing from the
great work that this committee does and
this isn't the time for us to to do
something that isn't that we don't all
feel is right so if there no objections
I would I would close well before I do
that if there are people who are
listening who would like to continue to
either contact the entire committee or
to contact one or two people on the
committee to see about maybe if come up
with something that would make sense I
would urge everybody to do it
we have almost this whole week it would
I think probably be necessary if there
is an amendment to have it go to OLS by
Monday morning so they can have they
need three days basically and they might
need a little bit more to do the
amendment and to get it out to the
public so this is not the way I wanted
to end our work and I don't know if
we're ever going to have a chance to
come back again and I'm not going to cry
about it because they're more important
things to cry about but if everybody's
okay then I adjourn this and I will look
forward to seeing all of you on the on
the 28th of 10:00 and I cannot thank you
enough for slogging through this for
participating as well as you have it for
this to go as smoothly as it could go
under these difficult circumstances
so I will see you on the 24th Rosie
there's there were two hands did you
want to recognize them or no no I think
we're done okay very good thank you okay